boots on the ground outside the European
Parliament across Europe the terror
levels have been raised in the wake of a
massacre of 17 people in Paris the
question now is how do we combat
terrorism in Europe and across the world
in the UK Prime Minister David Cameron
has come under fire for so-called
snoopers charter which gives
intelligence officials blanket access to
data on citizens so what's the
europe-wide approach find out more on
Wednesday when mvps debate new terror
laws at the plenary in Brussels could
all countries finally shake hands on a
UN climate change agreement in Paris end
of the year with China and the US now
commits a drastic emission cuts a deal
looks more promising but after the last
round of fractures climate talks and
Lima nothing can be taken for granted
what will be the outcome follow
discussion on the Paris conference by
any Peas also on the agenda for the
plenary back over the committee's were
the economic and civil liberties
committees will be putting new anti
money laundering legislation to a vote
key points the new law better access to
company information and creating better
vigilance by banks accountants and other
corporate actors the vote will be
followed by joint press conference find
out more on Tuesday afternoon another
item on the economic and Monetary
Affairs Committee agenda for the week
ahead a hearing with German Finance
Minister Wolfgang scheibler on economic
governance watch that on Tuesday morning
a game-changing trade deal or a curb on
national sovereignty it can only be T
tip one big controversy thrown up over
the us-eu trade deal GMOs still up in
the air despite new laws back by
Parliament allowing member states to
better control them the trade and legal
affairs committees will discuss t tip
with experts on Tuesday and that's what
we have this agenda take care and enjoy
the week